it's what happened Behind These Palace
walls on Tuesday night that has thrust
Britain's understanding of racism into
the spotlight once again and now for the
first time a prime minister of color has
waded in some of the things that I
experienced when I was a kid and a young
person I don't think would happen today
because our country's made incredible
progress in tackling racism but the job
is never done and that's why whenever we
see it we must confront it ngozi Fulani
took to social media to do just that the
charity chief executive is used to Royal
events here in 1997 teaching the then
Prince Charles how to play the drums so
her confrontation with Lady Susan Hussey
repeatedly asking where she was from
left her stunned at inability to accept
she was simply a black British woman she
says was insulting
I was not given the answer that she
wanted me to give and so we could not
move on and it was when she said ah you
would get there in the end that proved
to me you were determined
to prove that I had no right to a
British citizenship lady Hussey resigned
over the alleged comments bringing an
end to her six Decades of loyal Royal
Service the palace deemed her comments
unacceptable and her godson Prince
William condemned them too she may be
gone but miss villani says there is a
wider issue that needs addressing so
institutional racism is a problem all
over
the UK it's in the police it's been
established it's in the fire department
that was established it's even in parts
of the NHS it's a problem
and it's in Buckingham past of the one
person isn't responsible
ngozi's daughter who attended a
Buckingham Palace Garden Party earlier
this year says it's listening to why
such comments hurt that will lead to
change
when we talk about ignorance and when we
talk about ageism and when we talk about
all of the factors it's just not good
enough anymore I think people are really
used to racism being overt and if you're
not saying the n-word you can't identify
it as racism but it comes in passive
forms it comes as microaggressions it
comes as disrespect it's understood the
palace have shared their profound
regretto for the comments with Miss
Fellaini they stand ready to work with
her when she is ready but the healing
process will take more than words but
actions too Ashley Sky News